[Music]
amid the calm
there is conflicts in the countryside a
green and pleasant land it's seeing if
they carry on at the rate they're going
a battle of tradition this is the
countryside and what they're trying to
do it is make it into a town this is
those desperate for a home we were born
here we have a right to be here we're
second homes are second nature the guys
who wrote this live in London come three
for three or four times the area and
they just spend probably a week here at
a time while an increasing number are
being forced onto the streets the
clothes will wear something so nowhere
to dry them no money the rural housing
crisis is deepening a fight to put roofs
over heads and Kier Dilek countryside
tree alive
[Music]
twinning in Gloucestershire a chocolate
box village that dates back at least a
thousand years but in 2019 its boundary
is under threat away from the green
battle lines are being drawn so Jeff
where are we right now then well this is
the Bracco's paddocks development 59
houses finished this year one of two in
the in the parish the outline planning
application that we're now looking at is
for additional 50 houses on the field
over to our right
twinning already has a population of
around 1,500 but it's growing and too
fast for many what at my inquiries to my
solicitor before we moved in was is
there ever gonna be any building around
here it says in black and white here no
we don't want to tell we move from a
town it's very special to village and
our opinion is if you're going to build
why does it keep why'd you have to keep
building in fields how does it make you
feel if the fact that they if they do
get planning permission and you do get
another 50 homes in and that'll lead
into another 50 homes another 50 homes
another 50 homes and then we'll be
joined on 2 to 3 we will not be a
village anymore and that would negate
our reason for living here
so as village villagers you don't think
you're being listened to you know there
have been nearly 200 objections to the
new houses locals have spent years
drawing up plans to protect the village
what does it mean for the neighbourhood
plan if the planning permission is given
that would be a sad day really it would
mean that the neighbourhood plan had no
authority the policies within it were
not valid and really was not worth the
paper it's printed on what's happening
in twinning is mirrored in villages up
and down rural England councils under
pressure to build and villagers not
happy the Sayer family has just moved
into one of Twinings new estates which
was completed back in May without
affordable housing like this a family
home would have been impossible
we were private renting a two-bedroom
apartment
for over five years and we sort of
looked into buying but it wasn't viable
at the time so then we went on the
social housing list and got offered this
new build house three bit house it's
like Gloucestershire we've got you know
very pretty areas to living like
villages like this where houses are very
expensive it's not something you've must
have already come across when you were
looking at buying and living at your
housing options yeah yeah yeah there was
a new development being built where we
lived before in the apartment and the
house prices were really high on that
development it's just so hard to get
onto the property ladder nowadays yeah
official figures show more housing is
being built in rural England compared to
urban areas but Sky News along with the
Institute for Public Policy Research has
uncovered that the number of new homes
classed as social has fallen
dramatically between 2011 and 12 and
2018 the number of social houses built
in rural areas fell by 83 percent last
year just 1309 social homes were built
across the whole of rural England to put
that into context in Gloucestershire
alone there are nearly 17,000 people on
the waiting list for social housing
Kimberly and Brandon are among those on
the list I could imagine myself living
or something like that
I like the bricks and the windows it's
very old-fashioned born and bred in
Cirencester the capital of the Cotswolds
they're both work full-time but say they
can only dream of buying here young
people like us in wanting to buy even
wanting to rent they're definitely
making it so hard for us to stay here
it's like they want to get rid of the
young people from here and they want to
make it this angelic you know old
Victorian town that it was made of but
we were born here we have a right to be
here we shouldn't be forced out when
they face one people with with lots of
money to come here buy houses
and they don't give a damn about any
other people the prices are just
extortionate you look at and you're like
I'm not going to earn that in my entire
life let alone buy a house with it it's
easy to understand why young couples in
the countryside are disheartened
multi-million pound properties fill
estate agent windows and there's no sign
of affordable homes back in twinning
some of the new homes are yet to be sold
further fuel on the fire as to why more
and needed Maggie ball is in her 70s and
was born in the village it was home on
the side of the building was the dairy
and people used to come up the footpath
there with it the milk jugs in their
hand she's worried about the new
developments if they get the the
planning for that there we understand at
least five more
lots of builders waiting to say well
we'll have this field we'll have that
field and we'll have that the other
field so they will make it into a town
and how does that make you feel that
really distresses me this is a village
in my opinion it's not for the better
others will probably disagree with me
but we're all entitled to our view the
housing shortage in rural England isn't
just pushing people onto social waiting
lists it's sending them onto the streets
the nature of rural homelessness makes
it difficult to measure but exclusive
figures for Sky News showed that between
2012 and 18 the number of people
sleeping rough in rural England raised
by 33 percent the Institute for Public
Policy Research says that's down to
lower levels of affordable housing and a
high prevalence of second and holiday
homes
David Byrd has lived in cirencester for
15 years he's worked most of his life as
a farmhand but a few months ago he
became homeless my first night as well
it just sort of
yeah you know both because it was
staying light till about 10 o'clock at
night just sort of managed to get to
sleep about 11 o'clock very nervy didn't
sleep that well so this is where I live
now homeless bus for a fortnight on the
streets he found the big yellow bus a
double-decker converted by a charity to
house those sleeping rough and the
Cotswolds number two this is bunk number
three here which is Mari when it comes
down to being homeless you're an
outsider doesn't matter how much wealth
there is in the place is not that many
institutions to actually help the
homeless person cirencester is a very
conservative place it is a wealthy area
and yeah if you around sound sister with
no money in your pocket you feel very
very isolated if this bus haven't been
here I don't know really what would
still be out possibly yeah David told me
being homeless in the countryside is
harsher than the city travelling further
to find help and relying on small
charities like this like Cyrus tests are
even the sticks you wouldn't expect it
you gotta remember there's still people
out in the fields camping rough there's
something wrong somewhere a gentleman
come to the bus about three weeks ago
and he said some simple words they are
sorry
you said uh-huh Thank You Jerry you've
given me hope
know that it should just you know hits
you hard travel just four miles south
from the homeless bus and the rural
housing crisis comes sharply into focus
hundreds of luxury lakeside properties
exclusively sold as second homes after
you so this one is all about the open
plan nature of Italy but the views of
the water
this one's got a plunge pool which is
rather nice so the people who come here
but we come what three four weeks of any
year that's correct yeah not that often
and they might fit in the odd weekend
around that as well but generally
speaking by they live in London they
spend most of the time there around
1,500 second homes surround the
Cotswolds waterpark it's a whole range
of different types of people and you've
obviously to build thought something on
this she's got to be fairly successful
in what you do own your own your own
business there's quite a few of those
people around and also people of my sort
of generation now our properties are
worth so much more that they were really
done anything to get that and people are
beginning to remove their main homes and
buy one of these as well for the family
purpose-built second homes are one thing
but changing the face of England's rural
villages is another Friday evening at
the local Inn twinning and the future of
the village is on people's minds I know
the whole arguments about social housing
little things but ultimately it's about
developers and looking for places with
retail so they can make money for making
it's their job it's their job it's our
life with a very idyllic life here at
the moment I mean one gets to walk to
school so hundred metres from our front
door to school and I've got to your
fantastic pubs we've got lots of
wonderful things that go on here and I'd
hate for that to be diluted I suppose by
thousands of other people who just want
to keep the village life as it is I
recognize that you know the brown areas
are going to have to build up but just
to make sure they're still protect the
village I want my children to live here
but it just feels like a dumping ground
they
choose various spots they go for more
let's not get too big people here for a
reason
we'd like the rural life and let's keep
it that way
houses are less affordable in rural
areas compared to urban with prices
nearly nine times the average low wage
and although more so-called affordable
homes are being built for many they are
anything but it is a fancy but it's a
dream that will keep on dreaming until
it happens
and it will happen at some point in our
lives but developers are facing a fight
we've got a village school we've got a
pub we've got a shot but that doesn't
mean that you could suddenly throw in
that hundreds more people and it's
ripping up the farmland and building on
it and while the second home market
continues to boom we tend to attract
people at a cash wait time poor and if
you like the rural housing crisis means
many locals left struggling to keep a
roof over their heads there are benefits
and there they're sort of struggling
struggling to make ends meet
it's the house and have-nots and then
nothing is fair but
[Music]